(beeping)
- Maldonado is a pediatrician
and the Senior Associate Dean
for Faculty Development and Diversity,
Professor of Pediatrics and
Health Research and Policy,
and the Chief of the Division
of Pediatric Infectious
Diseases at Stanford.
We were really fortunate to
get Dr. Maldonado to come today
because she's usually off in some
distant part of the world
stamping out infectious diseases
or creating policy or whatever.
So Dr. Maldonado,
she will be talking about something
that I really don't
quite understand, SPHERE.
So can you educate us please?
Thank you.
- Yes, thank you Lucy,
it's great to see you.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I really wanna thank Lucy
for being very forward-thinking
about this topic.
It's something that
we're doing at Stanford
but it's also happening
all over the country now
and we thought, she thought
it would be a great idea
for you to hear about some of this,
the area of what we
call precision medicine.
How many people have heard
of precision medicine?
Okay, how many people know what it means?
Okay.
It's a tough situation
and it's a new concept.
I think it's actually
simpler than it sounds
but I'm going to spend the next 30 minutes
just giving you a high level overview
of what it is in a couple slides,
and then specifically showing you
what we are doing at
Stanford with this area.
Because it's gonna be something that
I think all of you need to
advocate around and understand.
So, let me just go back, sorry.
Is this a pointer? Yeah.
This is what our Stanford Medicine,
so we applied to the NIH.
They had a request for applications for
what was called precision
medicine and health disparities
and we didn't really
understand that either,
but we put together our own
idea of what we thought it was,
which I'll explain to you.
And we called our center,
because we all like acronyms,
especially Stanford.
We called it SPHERE
and it stands for
Stanford Precision Health
for Ethnic and Racial Equity.
Now, I know in this
group we're talking about
different disparities
but we thought, well, we'll start
with racial and ethnic disparities
but this can apply to disparities
in many different areas.
And so, I will explain this to you.
But first I just wanted to say
I am an advisor to Pfizer,
I am on the data safety monitoring board
for a vaccine study,
but otherwise I have no conflicts
relevant to the topic that
we're discussing today.
And so, when we talk about SPHERE,
the overall concept that we had is
that we, the idea of and I'll
explain a little bit more
about personalized medicine,
is really to take large data
that's available anonymously
and/or with permission
to really understand giant
high level patterns of disease
so that we can treat,
we can see those patterns
and then come focus in
on the individual person.
And rather than just say okay,
if everyone in here
developed a strep throat,
this is what I'm gonna give you all,
this is the one drug.
Obviously for that we can do it
but let's just say somebody
had and we've seen this happen.
Someone has cancer
and they have a particular kind of cancer.
And what we can do now
is we can take some,
in some cases we can
take those tumor cells
and sequence them, and
look at areas in that tumor
that are unique to that particular tumor
that might affect the
treatment that is involved
for that particular cancer in that person.
That's what precision medicine is about.
Taking the general knowledge
we have about diseases and health
and really focus them in on the individual
so that that person can get treated.
One of my personal
friends had oral cancer,
this was a couple, a few years ago,
able to get that cancer sent
off to some specialized lab,
they did the sequences, and they realized,
okay, this is the
chemotherapy that won't work
and here's the one that
will, and he was cured.
Now, he had a lot of money
and he had the ability to go to find
all these specialists that
were doing these studies
that weren't available
to lots of other people.
That's a big disparity already there.
And so, if you can apply
that to other areas,
for example, what about development,
risk for developmental disabilities?
What if we know that there are certain
genetic predispositions,
and we can say, this is
what you should be doing
if you're planning to have a child
or if your child, you had a child
and that child had issues or et cetera,
how do you know that you may be at risk
for particular manifestations
that we can try to prevent in XYZ manner.
This is really taking this
vast broad array of knowledge
and applying it to the individual,
and the ideas that eventually
your own physician, your
own health care provider
or your own practice
may be able to give you
information that you can
follow to help you understand
how your own genetic information
or your own environmental information
affects the way that
your health will play out
over the short term and the long term.
The other area there that's
important is to understand that
we all, I don't know if
you've talked about this today
or in other discussions
but we know now that only
about 20% to 40% of our health
in our long lifespan
is really dependent on
genetic and medical factors.
It turns out that 60% or
more of our health outcomes
are dependent on environmental factors.
And so if we understand
the impact of the environmental factors
on the genetic predispositions
that actually is going to go a long way
to helping us live longer healthier lives
or to treat diseases.
So that's really the
broad base understanding.
And so, we were focusing on
racial and ethnic disparities
primarily because the NIH wanted us
to focus in that area
and we thought okay Stanford has
all of this great experience
in genetics, genomics,
we can do all of these very
detailed lab based programs
but how do we translate that
into health in human beings
and people in the real world,
and people who actually
have less access to care?
And so that's where we pulled
the two communities together.
So this program now,
we're in our second year
and it's a $12 million grant
and we are focusing on identifying
genetic and biological markers
that we can use to help reduce disease
in minority populations in the US,
and I'll tell you
specifically how we're doing.
Now we're just one of about 12 centers,
other centers around the country
are focusing on different aspects
but they're all working
with minority populations
in order to try to understand
how we can reduce diseases
in these populations.
So we're trying to develop
first of all the analytic tools
to understand how to look at this data.
We're talking about very large data sets.
For example, genetic
sequences are run into the
hundreds and thousands and millions,
and how do you take
all those sequence data
from many people and try
to understand patterns.
And we're still trying to understand
at a national and international level
what kinds of analytic
tools we need to develop
to be able to do that.
It's kind of like looking
at the earth from space
and seeing the big picture
but when you're sitting here in this room
you really don't know where you are.
We need to have that very
high level analytic capacity
to be able to look at a gene.
The earth is a gene say
and say, oh look this part of the gene
regulates this and this
part regulates that,
and we need to understand
all of those things.
And these are the tools
we're trying to develop.
And then finally we want
this to be broadly applied.
In fact, at Stanford and UCSF as well
and other institutions,
precision medicine has
become a real calling card.
Now we all want to do this,
we all want to be able to
have our patients come in
and first of all do
prevention in the communities.
That's the most important part to say.
So, we want to keep people at home
rather than coming in sick.
And at Stanford we call
it precision health
rather than precision medicine
because the idea is we
don't want people to come in
and have a disease that we
have to diagnose, et cetera.
Obviously we will do it
and we will do the best we can.
We would love it to be health.
That is before you even get sick,
before you're even born
how can we give your family
markers kind of like
this 23andMe approach?
How do you know where you,
what your risks might be
and what might trigger them
so that we know ahead of
time how to keep it healthy?
So we talk about predicting and preventing
and then if we have to
treat, treating precisely.
That is the precise
disease that your body has.
And so those are the big concepts.
Now, (coughs) excuse me.
The project that we
have is centered in our
center for population health sciences
and population health is again
very similar to what I just described.
It is a study of relationship between
health determinants that
affect your health outcomes
in large populations.
And when you look at large populations
you can start seeing patterns popping up.
Certain people may be at higher
risk for certain problems.
For example we know
that stress in children
who are brought up in
stressful environments
actually have cellular markers of stress
in their cells that can
predict shorter lifespans
and other healthy outcomes
and we're just starting
to understand that.
So we need to understand how
our environment really affects our health.
And so, this is really at the intersection
of medicine and public health
because we need to work with communities
to make sure we're all engaged.
And in Stanford you can see the list of
different researchers that are involved
and this is people who are working
in many different areas.
Another one for example
in behavioral health
is the idea that we diagnose children
who come from very distressed backgrounds
with mental health disorders
at a higher rate than children who are
brought up in less
distressed environments,
and yet the new model now is the idea
and actually there are researchers
here at UCSF and Stanford
that are saying we're miss
diagnosing these children.
They don't have bipolar disease,
they don't have these other
diseases that we talk about,
they actually have some
form almost of PTSD.
And you don't treat that the same way
as you treat that bipolar
disease, et cetera
but we've been lumping
all of these together
and we're starting to try to understand
what the environment,
how that impacts your behavioral self
and how we can be better
at being much more specific
about individuals rather
than lumping them together
and possibly treating them with drugs
that may not work as well
or may not actually address the problem
that these people have.
So we're moving into that realm,
it's hard going because it's hard to find
the funds to do these things,
so we're very excited about
our opportunities here
to be able to start this process,
and people are doing this around the world
in other ways as well,
but we need better data
and better ways to understand.
So again, the idea of precision health
is to predict and prevent disease
and not just treat it,
that's really the idea.
And we tried and here again it says
imagine a time where your
doctor can really quickly
take a snapshot of your problem and say,
"Well, here are, this
is what we used to do
"but because your specific profile fits
"this particular treatment regimen
"this is what we would think
would work best for you
"and not for other people."
And we hope to get and we can do that
to a certain extent now
but we can be much better at it.
So, the aims of our center,
now this is where we talk
about our specific center.
These grants they have lots
and lots of requirements
so we have three research projects
and these are projects that are trying
to look at these ideas, how
can we translate this data
into understanding health disparities,
and we have five cores
and I'll show you a
little bit of what we do.
So, we want to implement
these three programs
with an integrated and
what we call a science team
and the team very much
includes our local community.
So everybody in the community
that is involved with this
really has a part in helping us
carry these projects forward,
and then we disseminate that information
to the communities as well.
And we actually develop as you see,
we expand relationships with our partners
in our communities so
that they can actually
inform us about how we should be working
and getting the information
out to communities
to help educate them based on
the information that we learn.
And finally again in the idea of
trying to understand tools,
we're just getting better
experience with these genetic
and biologic information sets
and really how do we understand
how certain subpopulations,
for example, right now we're
using race and ethnicity
but we could use other things.
So one of my colleagues is working on
gender and sex differences.
So, how do women respond
differently to drugs
and other treatments than men do
and we have virtually
no experience with that.
Because most drugs and most treatments
and most clinical studies in the world
for helping people out are done in men.
The people feel like it's
easier to work with men,
they're much more compliant, et cetera.
(audience laughing)
Right?
I mean yeah, that's what we hear,
that's what we hear
and we think well, so
women aren't compliant
and women won't come in?
I mean it's not been my experience.
I've worked with
preventing mother to child
transmission of HIV in African communities
and those mothers know that their children
lives are at risk.
They are almost 100% compliant
with everything we say.
So, I think this is this old notion that
it's just easier to use men
but it was really astounding.
It's only been in the
last five years or so
that we even understood
that most of the drugs
that are prescribed in the US,
most of the studies that have been done
around treatment of diseases
have been done primarily in males.
And it's not that they said no,
you can't be in the
study if you're a woman,
it's that well, the way
they cater to the people
who come into the trials
they attract more men,
they haven't really looked to get women in
and another big problem
which we have to deal with separately is
if you're at risk for becoming pregnant,
they don't want to have to deal with that
because then you might have
to drop out of the study
and you know?
So anyway, there's a lot of problems here.
By the way, it turns out
that most of the studies
and however you feel about animal studies,
there have been a lot of mouse studies
and up until five years ago all,
virtually every study done in mice
to look for drug development, et cetera
we're done in male mice.
Male mice.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, it seems easy
and the idea was well, but the hormones
are gonna muck up the studies
and then we won't understand if this,
well, but that's the point, right?
If a woman takes it, she has hormones too.
So basically when you put a drug in women
it turns out that it may
not work the same way
because of those pesky hormones.
Anyway, so now there's a
rule at the federal level,
you have to use, you have to explain
why you're not gonna use equitable
gender distribution in
your studies even in mice.
So anyway, yeah.
(audience laughs)
I just can't believe that we,
you just take certain things for granted
and then we found this out.
We're making slow baby steps forward.
This is the structure of our project.
The center is housed in the center for
population health sciences.
There's a steering committee
and an administrative core.
I run this with it with
the director of the center.
He has, this doctor is Mark Cullen
and Mark has worked in occupational
health work for decades.
That's where he's been working.
So primarily looking at bad
outcomes of health workers
in industrial settings and
how you can achieve this,
improve that and I'm an
epidemiologist as well
so I work on populations,
although I work in global
infectious diseases.
So the two of us really have this
broader population experience
and we have a lab core,
the statistical core,
an implementation core
and a consortium core.
Frankly, I think these two
are the most exciting cores.
these are great cores as well
but they are doing the
standard lab-based sequencing
and analytics, we're
developing again new tools
to try to understand how to
analyze these giant data sets.
They're just so big you
would take your lifetime
in using traditional methods
so we have to learn
new methods to do that.
But these cores are the ones
that really engage with the community
and we've done such a,
I feel like we've done a really
great job of reaching out.
And here are the three projects.
There's three big
projects and I'll go into
a brief description of them.
So, the first project is really exciting.
It's called BRAICELET and that stands for
Bio-Repository for
American Indian Capacity,
Education, Law, Economics and Technology.
So again, you really have to
work hard for that acronym
but it really does embrace
what they're trying to do.
So we have partners in South Dakota,
this is a Lakota Indian tribe
and they for good reasons are mistrustful
of sending their clinical samples off
to this person, that person.
They said we wanna do it ourselves,
can you teach us how to do that?
So we wanna run our own biobanks,
we wanna be able to understand ourselves,
what we wanna study,
how we wanna disperse that information
if at all if we keep it in the community
and what are the ethnic and ethical
and legal ramifications
of that kind of thing?
So for example, to what extent can we
have some of those
samples and help them out
because if you wanna keep
it within their organization
how does that happen?
And so, this is really exciting
because there are some health issues
within these communities
that are very unique to these communities
just like in other communities.
And they can actually collect the data
and then using other
partners including Stanford
but not necessarily only Stanford,
to try to understand how to analyze them
and see what risk factors they might have
for certain diseases and how they can
and more importantly, how you can predict
whether those there are ways to prevent
those diseases from occurring.
So this has been a really
exciting population,
these are some of our partners.
Here they are at Stanford
and here they are
again also at Stanford although
we've had many site visits there
and we're teaching them a lot,
and we're learning with them together also
about how to set up their own biobanks
and get them interested in their own,
taking charge of their own health.
I won't go through the aims but basically
the top high level area is really
to just establish this biobank
and try to help them do some pilot studies
just so that they understand on their own
what do they want to look at.
Now, it turns out that
this particular tribe
has a number of autoimmune illnesses
that even other Lakota tribes
within that same region do not have.
So, they wanna understand
how they're different
from these other groups.
Now, not only would it
help them to understand
why do they have this predisposition
and what are the risk factors
but might teach us about
autoimmune diseases
for all populations.
So, this is a study that they wanted
to undertake on their own
and we're gonna help them,
teach them how to do some of the studies
in their labs locally
and some of the work
that they can't do there,
we can pull over to
Stanford and help as well.
So, it's really an exciting opportunity
and then also at the same time
develop, implement and evaluate
health education and literacy.
One of the first things we
did with all of our projects
was bring our community partners in
and ask everybody what do you think
is precision medicine means
and what do you think
precision health means?
And everybody put their
own definition together
and then we all discussed it,
and we all tried to understand how
because everybody had great ideas
and it isn't one thing to all people.
And so, just getting that health literacy
out there is very important.
It gives people the ability to feel it,
that they can control in some ways
their own health outcomes.
The second project is
really closer to home,
it's called iPOP.
Again, little acronym.
So, Integrative
Personalized Omics Profiling
and Omics is a term that's
just generally means
the study of large
genetic or molecular data sets.
So we have genomics, we have metabolomics,
we have all of these, these omics
and we can take for
example one sample of blood
and you can study lots and
lots of different markers.
Well, one of my colleagues
at Stanford is a pediatrician
and he's been working in the
communities around San Jose
and Stanford for many years
among obese, young Latino kids
to try to do interventions,
health interventions,
help them to exercise more by dancing,
there are other things.
Just trying to see what
works in keeping kids active
and keeping their weight down.
And so, as part of this group
he's really established over the decades
a great relationship with these families.
And he asked them permission,
would you be willing to
give us a sample of blood
as we track you through.
So some of the kids are
having one intervention
and some are having a different one
to see if it helps with
their control of their weight
and other health markers.
These kids are at very
high risk for diabetes
and so he's tracking,
he asked for permission
to take blood samples
once a year from the kids
to see if we could track who predict
if there are genetic and other markers
that predict who might
go on to develop diabetes
or other other health issues.
And he got about 98% acceptance
because these are families
he's worked with for a long time.
And so, the the idea is really to pull out
all of the different molecular markers
in the blood that he's collected
and then understand patterns.
And again these are all anonymized
so the kids and the families
can get their data back if they'd like.
If they don't want to they
don't have to have it.
And the idea is it's really
try to understand if there
are again risk factors
for something that is very, very common
not only in the US but globally,
that is obesity and the
impact of that on diabetes
and other cardiac diseases for example.
So that's a very exciting project.
And so I just mentioned to
you what the goal is here.
Looking at these iPOP markers to measure
obesity and diabetes risk at baseline
and then to follow overtime to see how
this might affect this risk over time.
It would be wonderful if
we could take a blood test
from somebody and say this is your,
just like we have now for say
maternal screening for fetuses,
here's your risk of your
child developing XYZ disease.
This would be a great way to say
here's your profile that
you are at this much risk
for developing these diseases.
Of course he's also working
on the intervention side too
so that would be helpful to know
this would awaken the
family to this child,
you need to turn the television off
or you need to get them
outside, et cetera.
Those are but that can
help inform policies,
it will do that.
And then finally our third project
is really interesting also.
It's a different project,
it's how do we communicate
all of these information to patients
and how does that cultural,
how do different cultures
take up that information
and do they act on it and
if they don't, why not?
And part of this came up from
some reports that one of our physicians
had had over time where the people,
where they felt that a
lot of, based on your
ethnic and racial background
and your cultural background,
some people didn't wanna
know their genetic results.
Say for example from
breast cancer screening
they didn't wanna know,
they didn't wanna do anything about it
and other people were
very really hyper aware.
I wanna know what my markers are,
I wanna know what treatments will work
and other people just said
I don't really wanna hear it.
And it was really interesting
to hear about why that,
we don't really understand why that occurs
and so this project
will be a multi-ethnic,
multilingual two-site project
at Stanford and at USC
where we're going to focus on Hispanic
and Chinese and white women
who are being diagnosed
with breast cancer,
and really trying to help them
and how the doctors communicate with them
about that information.
And not only that, how
the communication style
works with that patient
and to see what they do with
that information over time
to understand how and why the information
had some uptake or did not have uptake.
It's really important,
all of us know we're not
supposed to smoke, drink,
we have to get a lot of x-rays, et cetera.
And yet, many of us, every one of us
has a different response to that.
So it would be helpful
to understand what is it,
how do you communicate
information in a better way,
in a way that can maybe get the best
health outcome for that person
or to understand what the obstacles
to communication might be.
So here the project is to assess
genomic confidence of
clinicians communicating this.
And that means you know
how well does the doctor
understand what they're
talking about basically.
And then there will be with,
again with permission, they're
audio taping the information
to be able to study how those
interactions are working
and whether there's keywords
that seem to be carried across
the successful interactions
compared to those
that are not so successful.
And then to identify when patients
share with their family members
and how that's influenced
by their health literacy
and other factors.
To see if we can overcome
some of the health disparities
that we see among racial and ethnic groups
that may not really have
sufficient health literacy
and how do we get them to that point.
So those are our three projects
and we have five years to work on them
and so far we're just enrolling
patients at this point,
and actually with the BRAICELET project
we're working with the Lakota group
to try to to help them
set up their biobank.
And so it's going reasonably well
and we don't have results at this point
but we work very carefully
with the community
and I talked to you about our five cores.
Our consortium core and
our implementation core,
great, we wanted to make them one core
but and I said no, you have
to have two separate one.
So we basically, functionally
they're one group,
we pull them all together.
So, this is just a picture of a meeting
that we had last year at Stanford
of some of our community
consortium members
from the actual projects.
But in addition to this group of people
we bring in partners
around the Stanford area
from different minority groups.
We have Vietnamese, Chinese,
African American, Latino,
other Asian subpopulations,
other groups as well
and really have them
come in and meet with us,
and review the data, the
work what we've done to date.
And we actually had a
really fun all-day session
with this group where we had people
present their own stories to each other
so that it was a really,
really unifying experience.
So, we're really trying to
create the strategic alliance
and build capacity for people to really
take control over their own health
and their own health literacy.
And then evaluate our projects
and the community members
know what's best for them,
so they tell us.
You know, we didn't really understand
why you did it this way,
we think you should do it this way.
And we really have been able
to build a better interaction
and I think better studies
and programs in the long run
to be able to speak in the language
that people understand best.
We also have some really
nice opportunities.
The NIH allowed us to
grant a few pilot grants
to our community members
so they can go out and do
their own pilot work in their communities.
A lot of these are around
health education and
health literacy education,
and so we're in our second round,
we're just gonna be awarding
our second set of grants
in the next couple of months.
And so these are our partners,
this again is that group here you saw.
We had our annual meeting
and then we have...
We bring people back
and forth quite a bit.
We travel there to the different sites
but we also bring people in
so that they can get to know one another
and really understand the overall
objectives of this project.
And so, the implementation core is really
meant to try to create some guidelines
so that communities can have something
to communicate back into their populations
based on what we have learned so far
about how to work together.
And we are trying to
understand what the best way is
to communicate with
populations around the area
given that they may have obstacles,
maybe there's language obstacles,
cultural obstacles, just
transportation obstacles.
So one of the things we found out
is that most of the
people didn't wanna have a
conference at Stanford.
They were afraid to come to Stanford,
it's too big, it's a little intimidating.
They prefer to have it in
their local community center.
We couldn't afford to
have that many meetings
so we did have individuals
going out to the community centers
but when we had our big meeting
we had it in a little,
a more low-key building
and really engaged the community that way.
But we were really surprised
that people just felt
and they also didn't want
to have it in the hospital
and that part we can understand.
The hospital's certainly intimidating.
And so we had it on
campus but off in another
like a undergraduate building.
So you learn a lot about
how people wanna be messaged
and I think we've
learned a lot about that.
And again I mentioned the
analytics and modeling core
really trying to come up with cutting edge
statistical methods to understand
how to process large amounts of data
in a way that really is meaningful.
And then our lab core does
all the laboratory studies
and so far we've had many
or finally we've had many
visits to the different site
particularly in South Dakota
but other sites as well.
We have had these focus groups over time,
we continue to do that
and we have a lab core
partnership in Mexico.
They're trying to do
the same thing in Mexico
looking at genetic
predisposition to immune markers
that predict immunity
to develop to vaccines,
and so they wanted to partner with us.
And we had our annual
Community Consortium meeting
which was really exciting
all really run by the community members
telling their stories about
how their diseases were,
were not handled well
and what they thought might work better.
It was really edifying for a lot of us
and across the board
and we also have been publishing work.
So, I'd like to stop there
and thank you so much for your attention.
(audience clapping)